aguántenlo mamita
aguante la aguántenlo si bien la
práctica puede sorprender es milenaria
las comadronas llevan ayudando a las
mujeres a dar a luz desde el principio
de los tiempos no son médicas ni
enfermeras ellos no lo practican eso
solo las comadronas hacen esto para
bajar el bebé en la Guatemala de hoy
según el Ministerio de salud de un 42%
de los partos es prestado por comadronas
tradicionales pero pocas son tan bien
equipadas ni capacitadas como ese grupo
antonina con 39 años de ser comadrona es
testigo de una época con muchos menos
recursos Pero mi mamá Ella tuvo 13 hijos
el primero nació muerto segundo muerto
tercero muerto cuarto muerto Por qué
Porque la comadrona no tenía ese equipo
anteriormente
una vez al mes visitan a las comunidades
de su región y por menos de un dólar
proporcionan a las futuras mamás
ecografías vitaminas prenatales y
consejos come suficiente pero para estas
mujeres un detalle en particular es más
importante que cualquier formación
académica
en las comunidades las comadronas saben
hablar mam el mismo idioma que hablan
los pacientes entonces con las
comadronas tienen muchísimo más
confianza
y donde el uso de material moderno más
puede salvar vidas es en el delicado
momento de un parto
en Guatemala aproximadamente 115 madres
fallecen durante el parto por cada
100.000 nacidos vivos representa la tasa
de mortalidad materna más alta de
América Latina y las más expuestas son
las mujeres indígenas
además de tranquilizarlas en su idioma
las comadronas dejan a sus pacientes dar
a luz en sus trajes tradicionales en el
hospital pues
la paciente se puede poner a la posición
que los médicos quieran en cambio aquí
pues en la posición o a la comodidad de
la paciente por ejemplo ella no podía
pujar estar acostada Entonces ella
prefirió ponerse de jucías para poder
pujar
Buenos días
las pacientes indígenas no son las
únicas en sufrir de discriminación en
las instituciones médicas urbanas de
parte de los médicos
pues nosotras como comadronas nos llaman
como personal no calificado que
manipulamos a las pacientes sin tener un
conocimiento pero sí sufrimos mucho de
la discriminación y el racismo y por no
tener un título elevado ni haber
estudiado en una universidad
es para paliar estas discriminaciones
que nació en 2004 esa casa materna
formando la asociación de comadronas del
área mam atienden partos y ofrecen
consultas médicas que hemos tenido
recibido muchas capacitaciones para
fortalecer la habilidad y que gracias a
eso pues no hemos tenido muerte materna
durante todos los años que hemos
trabajado eso es azúcar de leche
Entonces no hay necesidad de darles
otras cosas esto se combina con las
plantas medicinales las plantas
medicinales son El dominio de Azucena
Esto es para un té ahorita en posparto
dientes de León y Hinojosa Elvia Santa
se usan para prevenir complicaciones en
el parto aliviar dolores y acompañar la
madre Durante cada etapa de su embarazo
a veces en baño caliente se le hace a la
señora aquí para que así pueda relajarse
y producir leche después del parto sin
embargo Azucena insiste en que las
plantas no reemplazan los medicamentos
es la planta que primero se da para que
quite lo que es la infección si es muy
fuerte estás tiene sangrado la señora en
la orina encima hace una fuerte
infección Entonces si tienes que tomar
medicamento esa voluntad de mantener el
conocimiento ancestral cobra vida en una
de las integrantes de la casa materna
Buenos días Evelyn con sus 16 años es la
comadrona más joven de la asociación
acam su entrada en el mundo de la salud
maternal tuvo un carácter espiritual por
medio de un ritual
marcarín primero hice la pregunta
y ahí marcó que sí es ese su suerte eso
lo que su trabajo lo que iba a hacer
porque es su destino para cumplir con la
predicción Evelyn planea ingresar en una
universidad de medicina y así fortalecer
su experiencia de comadrona Tal vez para
mantener y preservar
las comadronas en la cultura y no
sacarlas y no es solo la preservación de
esta herencia Maya lo que está en juego
sino que en un país con niveles tan
bajos de atención prenatal en naturaleza
depende de yo la salud de cientos de
mujeres